gestern gab es ja eine interessante
szene noch annika als sich armin laschet
mit angela merkel in einem café
getroffen hat du warst vor ort und hat
dann noch mal nachgefragt werden bezahlt
hat und wie viel trinkgeld es gab
genau nämlich gar keins die beiden haben
sich in aachen auf dem abteil platz
getroffen da gab es noch mal eine
abschlusskundgebung also laschet war ja
vor paar tagen schon bei merkel in
stralsund zu gast der zwar wie eben bei
ihm in aachen zu gast vorher haben sie
sich ein paar hundert meter ganz alleine
in einem café getroffen in einer kleinen
ab seite sozusagen damit sie ungestört
reden konnten da gab es dann espresso
und wasser für 20 euro 10 gezahlt hat am
ende merkel sekretärin wird nun leider
bisschen das trinkgeld vergessen und
genau das brauchen wir jetzt einmal ganz
kurz reinschauen an die maz
so geizig hätten wir kanzlerkandidat
armin laschet und bundeskanzlerin angela
merkel jetzt aber nicht eingeschätzt am
samstag tritt armin laschet in aachen
auf es ist die abschlussveranstaltung
der union vor der bundestagswahl
an seiner seite stargast angela merkel
für überraschungen sorgten schnitt bei
seiner rede nicht wirklich dafür aber
bei seinem besuch davor angela merkel
und er machen nämlich einen abstecher
ins café gutes gönnen sich espresso und
ein glas wasser auf der rechnung standen
am ende 20 eur 10 und dann das wird am
ende bezahlt
die sekretärin von frau merkel zu
trinken
kein problem bild springt natürlich
gerne ein unsere reporter haben dass
kanzler trinkgeld übernommen und ein
euro schein auf
[Musik]
janika und sehr lustige
sehr großzügig dass er dann ein
gesprungen seid aber es ging dann ja
noch weiter
genau am ende kam armin laschet und doch
noch mal in dem café vorbei und hat sein
eigenes portemonnaie gezückt und eben
das trinkl dann doch noch gezahlt eben
auch bei dem kellner den wir eben gerade
in dem beitrag gesehen haben mit dem wir
gesprochen haben es gab also dann
doppelt trinkgeld für das café machen
oder sich nicht nehmen lassen sehr schön
und das alles weil wir berichtet haben
ist doch auch mal ganz nett
[Musik]